Westworld season 2 episode 2 begins with
Dolores and Arnold 35 years ago
Arnold shows her a city in the real
world possibly in China near the
west-world Island Dolores is odd with
the beauty of this place Arnold says
most people don't see the beauty in the
world but hosts like Dolores and
children like Arnold's son Charlie have
the naivety or the courage to see the
world with all its wonders and
possibilities this is why Arnold loved
the hosts and wanted them to be free
though ironically the freed hosts lose
this innocent optimism in the present
Dolores attacks a West world facility
she says she used to see the beauty in
this world but now she sees the truth
Dolores shows Teddy his deaths and abuse
in West world she opens his eyes to evil
it's like in the Bible when a veyts the
forbidden fruit then gives a taste to
Adam the fruit gives them knowledge of
good and evil original sin so they're
cast out of the Garden of Eden just like
Dolores and Teddy lose that innocence
that Arnold loved now that they know
good and evil Dolores and Teddy are free
to choose
Dolores chooses violent vengeance what
will Teddy do back in the past Arnold
and Ford are trying to get investment
for the early West world from the delos
corporation so they send the hosts
Angela Anna catch a turtle Logan Delos
the son of company head James Delos so
this happens before season 1 when Logan
and William visit the park Angela and a
catch at her take Logan to a party where
everyone's a host to show off how
advanced their robot tech is and Logan
gets a hands-on demo with Angela so
Logan is convinced to invest in
Westworld and he becomes a regular at
the park then season 1 happens
Logan's sister Juliet gets engaged to
William so Logan takes William to West
world will mates Dolores then embraces
his dark side and his credits Logan so
that William replaces Logan as James
Dallas's favorite in this same after
season one William convinces James
dillos to invest even more in West world
he pitches the big secret day loss plan
which is
about collecting data on guest behavior
because in the west-world park people
feel free to reveal their true desires
just like william did in season 1
if Delos records and analyzes this
behavior they could use the data to
predict and control people's choices
just like Facebook and Google and
YouTube do remember to like and
subscribe later we see a retirement
party for James William is taking over
the Dallas company and there are hints
of tension here William is taking power
from James and James seems sick he's
impatient for progress on something does
he mean some medical development do they
want to put James's brain in a robot
body or something from the looks of the
trailers James's story is far from over
we see Williams wife Juliet and their
daughter Emily but William has also
brought Dolores which is kind of creepy
to keep her around as scenery after
having fallen out of love with her last
season and Will's wife Juliet looks
unhappy to see Dolores he gotta wonder
how much she knows about will and
Dolores as a relationship we know from
last season that eventually Juliet
commits suicide because of the darkness
in William we see Logan moping and doing
some sci-fi drugs as you would if your
father rejected you and gave the family
business to some other guy Dolores comes
to look and possibly sent by William to
taunt Logan as though to Loras is some
cruel trophy of Williams victory over
Logan Logan says that Delos will cause
the whole [ __ ] species to burn what
does he mean that day losses secret
dollar project will hurt humanity that
West world will make people dark and
cruel like William or does Logan foresee
the robot uprising he clearly knows
something it'll be cool to learn more
about Logan's fate because we've never
seen him in the present timeline his
Logan even still alive we see William
visit Dolores who acts passive and mute
in the park last season William thought
love for Dolores transformed him but now
with Dolores reduced to a thing
William realizes it was self-discovery
that changed
in a different light this could be a
positive message to self-actualize
without defining yourself by others but
unfortunately the self that William
discovers is a sociopathic asshat and he
has plans
William shows Dolores some kind of
construction project connected to the
data collection plan he says it's an
answer to a question no one's ever even
dreamed of asking and this place becomes
the big mystery of this episode
cuz now 35 years later both William and
Dolores are trying to return to this
place old William the man in black
rescues the host Lawrence from some
other hosts the party brothers will says
that in this narrative loop Lawrence is
meant to escape from the brothers
himself but since all the hosts have
gone rogue they're acting differently
one brother gets up and keeps fighting
after William shoots him dead so the
rules of the west-world game have
changed the difficulty has increased the
enemies have more HP and it's Ironman
Nuzlocke mode you can die for real so
William has to use all his knowledge of
the game to survive he goes to a bar and
grabs a hi-tech health pack from a wall
like that chicken in Castlevania William
is determined to beat this endgame quest
but then he says that Westworld
is going down in flames and everyone's
gonna die but it's not clear why does he
think Dolores is war will kill them all
or does this connect to what Logan said
about the species burning
whatever the reason Williams excited by
this apocalypse says it's a chance to
see what we're really made of a glimpse
of the men we could have been it's a sad
dumb tragedy that William has spent
decades so obsessed with discovering his
true self that he never got around to
living his life being himself so all
that's left for him now is a glimpse of
what he could have been William is a man
defined by his past and regrets Williams
says Delos has been watching tallying up
people's sins in the park he must mean
the guest data project that he himself
started 30 years ago William says he
built this
place and it's his greatest mistake he
says he's been judged for his sins in
the park and he does have many sins but
he thinks judgment is unfair because why
should he be judged for hurting robots
when the robots were meant to be just
mindless machines the stakes weren't
real so William wants to appeal the
verdict clear his name then burned the
whole thing to the ground so if this
mysterious place is where the west-world
data is stored
maybe William wants to wipe his files to
avoid judgment but with all the talk of
burning apocalypse and God and a
question there must be some deeper
meaning here William and Lawrence head
to pariah and mate L Lazo as William
points out L Lazo was a role played by
Lawrence back in the season one timeline
Lazo talks about his Revolution
storyline says that now he's reached its
end he sees that it was empty all along
just like Hector with that safe the
freed hosts are realizing that their
lives are lies scripts written to
entertain guests so what do they do with
themselves now William could face the
same problem what if he reaches the end
of his find the door quest and just
feels empty
what next Lazo finds no joy in quests so
he refuses to help William with his
journey and then Lazo tells a story
about how elephants can be trained to
stay in place with just a stake if the
elephant learns from a young age that
it's too weak to escape it won't even
try when it's older and stronger the
lesson is that sometimes were held back
not by the realities of our situation
but by our beliefs and our fears are now
past maybe for William to truly escape
Westworld he needs to let go of his past
with Dolores Logan tell us Robert says
last episode that Williams quest ends
where he began William tries to recruit
Lazos men but Ford's programming kicks
in and the hosts all kill themselves so
that William can't use them even after
his death Ford still manipulates William
which raises the question of just how
much control Ford has over this broader
storyline Dolores meanwhile chokes of
in robot yogurt to make him tell her
Dallas's security plan apparently
they're rallying hundreds of men which
is probably what we saw on that beach
last episode Dolores only has like 50
hosts so she needs allies if she is to
win this war she meets Maeve and tries
to recruit her to the robot revenge
party but Maeve's not interested she
points out the hypocrisy of how Dolores
commands people when she says she stands
for freedom Maeve pointedly asks Teddy
if he feels free maybe after getting
woke this episode Teddy will finally
start making his own decisions on what's
right Dolores then mates with
Confederate our soldiers who were
cosplaying as the Last Supper apparently
they're headed to glory aka the valley
beyond which seems to be that same place
where Williams headed if the Confederate
oohs are like the apostles of the Last
Supper Dolores is the Jesus cos when the
soldiers threaten Dolores she says to
forgive them because they don't know any
better which is totally a Jesus
catchphrase Dolores then murders them
all which is less jesusí but then she
uses her Westworld tech to resurrect
their leader Craddock like how jesus
resurrects Lazarus Dolores then claims
to have killed God which is true in the
sense that she killed West world's
creator Ford Dolores tells Craddock that
he'll need her favor to reach glory so
there are heavy religious themes here
Dolores frames herself as a messianic
figure but she also claims to have
killed God so maybe she's more like
Satan a fallen angel who rebels against
God Dolores marches on with her
Confederate o army including the
resurrected Craddock there is something
about leading an army of undead
Confederate soldiers that gives off a
kind of a bad guy vibe
not to mention Dolores is torture and
murder of innocent people she does have
a bit of a breaker of chains Daenerys
feel sometimes but can also seem a bit
like the night King what with the
exterminating humans thing is Dolores a
hero or is she a villain
Dolores talks with Teddy about glory he
says that glory and the valley beyond
all names for the same place and Dolores
equates it with Williams place of
judgment the del estado project she says
she knows what's there because Williams
showed her and she was present at his
pitch 30 years ago
Dolores says that this place is a weapon
and she'll use it to destroy them if
glory is the place where guests behavior
data is stored
maybe Dolores plans to release the data
to show the world all the awful things
that Westworld guests have done it would
be like in South Park when everyone's
internet history's made public it could
cause chaos but the weapon seems
something bigger than that it's tied to
these ideas of judgment fire-god an
answer to a question that no one's ever
dreamed of asking and the flooded Valley
with the drowned hosts last episode
seems related so this is shaping up to
be the central mystery of the season and
it is kind of hard to imagine a payoff
that justifies all this hype like the
maze was the center of last season and
it paid off in only very vague ways so
maybe we shouldn't expect hard answers
here but this episode does make sense in
a way that most of last season didn't
back then we didn't know characters
motivations which people were robots or
even which timeline was which but this
episode is pretty clear we get the
backstory of Arnold and Logan and Delos
while in the present Dolores fights her
war against humans Maeve tries to find
her daughter and William pursues his
quest we know who people are and what
they want which gives the show space to
explore some cool themes from the Bible
to modern technology to elephants so let
us know in the comments what you think
of this new West world if you want more
Westworld videos from alt shift X
support us on patreon for a few bucks a
month you get updates early videos topic
votes and more thanks to patrons Lisa
Mitchell Rob de rozier Wu Tang Micah
chthonic Park Vita M sorry
and David T shears
you